It’s not easy being green.
Just ask Venus.
Hello!
I’m Ian O’Neill, space producer for Discovery
News, and I thought I’d pop into the studio
today to talk about a planet that rarely gets
much press, even though it’s considered
Earth’s evil twin.
I am of course talking about Venus -- a world
that’s closer to the Sun than Earth is,
but has an environment that is EXTREMELY hazardous
to life.
Well, for LIFE AS WE KNOW IT, anyhow.
(There might be little cloud-floating aliens…
who knows!
But that’s for a different episode.)
For a long time, Venus remained a tantalizing
mystery for astronomers -- the thick hazy
atmosphere completely obscured its surface,
keeping it a well guarded secret.
But after decades of observations by telescopes
on the ground, unmanned spacecraft flybys,
plus a Soviet lander and balloon-borne atmospheric
probe (yes, we’ve floated a balloon in the
atmosphere of another planet!), we’ve come
to realize that Venus is a deeply fascinating
place.
But we won’t see astronauts exploring its
surface any time soon -- because, ya know,
they’d MELT.
So we tend to focus more attention on Earth’s
red sibling, Mars.
Now that the European Space Agency has the
Venus Express satellite in orbit around Venus,
there’s been a lot more interest in the
clouded planet and the mysteries its atmosphere
contains -- and one of the most mysterious
things about Venus is its green glow.
On Earth, we have the aurora -- also known
as the Northern, or Southern Lights.
When seen by the naked eye, we see predominantly
green light at high altitudes, but the aurora
comes in a whole range of colors.
The aurora happens more frequently during
times of high solar activity, so when the
Sun throws a coronal mass ejection, basically
a vast magnetized bubble of high energy particles,
in Earth’s direction, our planet’s global
magnetic field deflects the particles and
injects them into the Earth’s poles.
The high energy particles, mainly protons
and electrons, slam into the high atmosphere,
causing atmospheric gases to generate light.
The green light we often see is oxygen emissions
and at the same time we’ll also see a red
emission, that is also oxygen atoms, only
at higher altitudes.
But Venus doesn’t have a global magnetosphere
like Earth, so for the past 40 years, astronomers
have been trying to understand whether or
not Venus can even have auroral activity.
Using a high resolution spectrometer attached
to the 3.5-meter telescope at Apache Point
Observatory in New Mexico, researchers were
able to spot green emissions from the Venusian
ionosphere when coronal mass ejections slammed
into the planet.
However, these emissions were more diffuse
all over the Sun-facing side of the planet
as there is no magnetosphere to concentrate
the high-energy particles at the poles, like
Earth.
Also, there was no sign of red aurora activity
at high altitudes.
Now they are trying to understand what chemical
reaction is causing this green glow; is it
the small quantities of molecular oxygen in
the atmosphere, or is something else going
on?
More Earth-based observations and help from
Mars Express are needed.
This is an exciting result as we are beginning
to understand how space weather impacts planets
without global magnetic fields, including
Mars.
All in a day’s work for our space weather
forecasters...
Do you have any wild theories to explain why
Venus produces this green glow?
Let us know in the comments below and please
subscribe for more DNews every day of
the week.